Donnie it's great to see you here in
London with your latest film kung fu'
jungle which isn't screening here at
London Film Fest and now you've worked
with the director before haven't you but
how did it compare working together on
your previous project it's been five
years and usually usually I work with a
lot of people but teddy is the second
time you know we know each other for
quite some times and yeah although it
took him five years to come up with this
projects but I think it's well worth it
and you were your co-stars in number
them before as well haven't you yes
mobile challenge yes we did a movie
called
I spent last year so this is our second
time working together now what kind of
challenges did you face when you're
making this particular movie I think the
biggest challenge was action directing
Ma Bell channel my fellow actors he
played the villain and he's a very
famous comedian actor in China he's not
known for making action films so in the
beginning was quite challenging for me
to recommend our investors and even
teddy to have him play this this role
but uh but I felt that he have
tremendous potential and then I want to
take up that challenge and it gives me
great satisfaction to see the result and
you know especially last night the
review has been great and I think you
know he did a fantastic job I focused
more on the actor and director I mean I
mean I said as an actor I mean I tried
to do the best I can every film anyway
right but this time around was
challenging because knowing that that I
have to turn him into someone that uh
you know equally as powerful on screen
as myself so that was that was quite
something in the beginning I mean what's
made you most proud about for this
particular film either a moment in it or
something during the shoot I
again you know it was a combination of
of putting kungfu
a straight-up confer story collaborating
collaborating with thriller suspense and
and for the first time and action
directing summer like walmart channel
and yeah I think it's quite quite
combination of many many things I've got
to talk to you a little bit about other
things you got coming up as well course
sir everyone's looking forward to
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon the sequel
what can audiences expect everyone's
waiting with bated breath well it's
going to be in English I think that's
totally a new take on it it's going to
be on Netflix it's going to be viewed by
36 million subscribers and and I think
that the fans are been waiting for
decades so it's gonna be very exciting
yeah it's been over 15 years now hasn't
it you mentioned Netflix of course it's
premiering on Netflix as well as IMAX it
separated little somewhat controversial
maybe with the cinemas themselves and
what are your kind of thoughts about
that controversial is good they create
buzz you know it brings awareness that
mean everybody is talking about and when
when a project has been talked about so
so much that that's a former for is an
act of myself you know that's a win-win
situation of course you were a new
director this time when you in a way
because obviously he was the
choreographer and fight director on the
previous film and what does he bring to
the sequel you think that's gonna be a
surprise guys
spoil it you guys watch it I was filming
going at the moment in New Zealand
wrapped two days ago for to make the
London premiere I believe they have two
more weeks to go it's going to be all
done and you know we see when the film
comer wrote it and as well there's also
it man 3 what kind of stage are you at
with that and what can audiences expect
from this
in the trilogy we startingly makes much
so again I can't really tell you the
story but it's gonna be my last time
around playing it man and I think the
fans has been waited for quite a quite a
few years and and I kind of didn't
wanted to take on this role again and I
was on to experimenting different
different characters different rows
until I'm ready and I feel like I'm
ready so we'll see you know and I try to
do the best I can and hopefully I can
top the first two you talked in the past
you talked to Jackie Chan and Jet Li
about some Chinese Expendables movie and
I know you were talked about you
approach for Expendables 1 & 2 weren't
you which you turned down I mean one of
the chances we'll see a Chinese
Expendables and what kind of cars would
you like to see in that oh you know
actually it's funny you mentioned it you
know months ago at his conversation with
Jackie and I kind of brought the ideas
if you know what why don't we make our
own Chinese expendable you know and he
kind of told me well you got to talk to
Jet Li if she convinced gently do it you
know I said oh hey let me try to talk
them it was just a casual conversation
but I never really was a serious
follow-up projects that we were aiming
at but who knows you know I mean you
know if if destiny it was gonna happen I
think is a brilliant I think it's cool
idea
would you like to see you know every
everybody Under the Sun maybe every
Chinese action guy in the film that
would be very fun it's been lovely
talking to you darling thanks so much
for your time thank you
you